[Musique]
prendre du plaisir une notion
essentielle pour océane trois apprentis
en restauration la jeune femme travaille
en alternance sur cette péniche amarrée
sur les quais d'auxerre sociable à
l'aise avec la clientèle océane
s'épanouit
du coup ça s'est bien passé samedi pour
faire ce métier là il faut être
passionné
faut aimer ce qu'on fait sinon on enfin
on y prend pas de plaisir
est-ce qu'on n'a pas de week-end les
autres quand il sort bas nous on est au
travail quand nous on est en repos bas
les autres sont au travail
donc c'est une vie totalement différente
une petite nordique avec une salade
après un bac de gestion et une année de
bts assurance océane a choisi de se
reconvertir dans la restauration et
d'apprendre un nouveau métier un profil
atypique qui a retenu l'attention de sa
patronne
au sénat la une très belle démarche à la
fiancée de cuisine d'abord les instincts
sap et de services donc je trouve que la
démarche est intéressante pour un futur
pour elle dans sa vie perso et du coup
elle avait déjà de l'expérience d'un
restaurant d'un bar de du service
[Musique]
c'est tombé dedans quand j'étais petit
par rapport à mon cousin il m'a transmis
sa passion ma mère pareil grande
cuisinière toujours à faire des petits
plats sympathique donc du coup ça m'a
vraiment donné envie d'intégrer ce
milieu tu vas des couples et petit à
petit je vais tomber voilà et après tu
vas 1,6 et au niveau des ailes et au
niveau de la cuisse quand elle n'est pas
au travail
océane est à l'école dans ce centre de
formation en alternance qui aux côtés de
ses professeurs
elle dit après l'exigence du métier ici
aussi son profil a séduit el paso ces
apps et hôtellerie cafés restauration en
un an au lieu de deux elle a la maturité
on va dire l'expérience la maturité elle
a vraiment choisi le métier dans lequel
il s'engage donc pour nous c'est une
jeune fille avec un profil intéressant
de bonnes connaissances scolaires de
bonnes bases au niveau de la scolarité
donc l'apprentissage est beaucoup plus
facile on va beaucoup plus loin avec des
jeunes filles qui ont ce profil au cifa
océane continue son apprentissage sans
la peur de mal faire de ce trou eric
salles avantage d'être théorique et
pratique en même temps on apprend tout
en exerçant le métier qu'on aime c'est
comme si on était en entreprise en fin
de compte avec plus d'exigence que
dans nos entreprises mais on fait
exactement le même travail
vu que pendant nos pratiques on sert des
clients aussi à 21 ans océane a déjà de
nombreux projets une fois son ca fait en
poche la jeune femme voudrait pas faire
son expérience et travailler à
l'étranger avec le rêve d'ouvrir un jour
son propre restaurant